bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france en on le disait
avec lucas léger c'est un fait rarissime
une perquisition ainsi dans un ministère
pourquoi maintenant oui la question peut
se poser alors c'est parce que cette
plainte a été déposée il ya quelques
temps et que sans doute l'enquète
avancer il faut savoir s'il y avait
effectivement conflit d'intérêt ou non
entre le garde des sceaux qui était
avocat avant de devenir ministre de la
justice est assez cocasse d'avoir
l'avocat du ministre pendant que le
ministère est perquisitionné par les
magistrats on sent bien qu'il ya une
guerre interne qui fait rage au sein de
l'institution judiciaire entre se garde
des sceaux déjà affaiblir par les
régionales et d'autres choses et les
magistrats qui essayent de reprendre la
main finalement sur l'appareil
et pourquoi maintenant et bien sans
doute parce que les régionales sont
passées et qu avant les régionales
on y aurait vu une manoeuvre politique
même si on peut toujours se poser la
question bien sûr de l'aspect politique
de cette perquisition quand on voit les
moyens qui sont déployés ça rappelle ce
qu'on avait vu lors de la perquisition
des locaux de la france insoumise et de
l'appartement de jean luc mélenchon où
il y avait là aussi des policiers en
armes avec leur gilet pare-balles qui
étaient là pour montrer la force
simplement de la justice ou bien
perquisition lors de
dans les locaux du journal en ligne
mediapart par exemple alex est un signal
de plus peut-être qui montre combien le
ministre est affaibli au sein du
gouvernement ce moment oui on sent eric
dupond-moretti bien seul même s'il a son
avocat à ses côtés c'est une suite qui
quand même rend difficile sa position au
sein du gouvernement on se rappelle la
campagne catastrophique dans les hauts
de france 1 où il a été balayé dès le
premier tour
on l'a vu faire campagne et d'ailleurs
il a été moquée vu qu'il était avec
rolex des boutons de manchette enfin
montres de luxe et boutons de manchette
à coller des affiches chose qu'il avait
peu l'habitude de faire cette défaite
n'a pas aidé bien entendu et puis il ya
eu ensuite la la passe d'armes entre
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
eric dupond moretti qui ont très mal
pris une lutte d'égos qui passe très mal
au sein du gouvernement le en même temps
tiré à la limite de l'explosion entre
une personnalité issue des dlr gérald
darmanin et puis un électron libre
plutôt proche des idées du parti
socialiste qui serait eric
dupond-moretti du mois comme il s'en
revendiquent
et donc on voit bien que le ministre
aujourd'hui avec cette perquisition perd
encore de sa superbe y avoir bien du mal
à défendre sa position au sein du
gouvernement et on peut se demander
d'ailleurs si l'exécutif était au
courant de cette perquisition
si parce que quand même elle touche un
ministre du gouvernement
donc c'est assez étonnant comme
procédure et c'est vraiment assez
explosif à ce moment est évidemment
après les régionales après tout ça est
ce que eric dupond moretti a encore sa
place dans un gouvernement de campagne
puisqu'il révèle mâcon va lancer sa
campagne et souhaite sans doute aller
davantage vers les électeurs de droite
comme il le montre avec sa volonté de
poursuivre les réformes avec aussi
toujours cette ce discours très qui
cherchent à draguer les électeurs de la
droite classique donc clairement dans
les jours qui viennent les semaines qui
viennent peut-être que le remaniement
qui n'aura pas lieu fra fra fra jours à
nouveau ministre de la justice ou du
moins dupond-moretti va se faire
discrets alors pas si discret en tout
cas aujourd'hui 1
puisque eric dupond moretti a envoyé
valser une députée qui voulait
intervenir des drapeaux étrangers lors
des mariages alors avant de vous faire
réagir et que vous nous apportiez votre
analyse vous propose d'écouter cette
petite passe d'armes
elle semblait certaines familles
françaises ou non d'origine étrangère au
moment des mariages parfois dans la
salle des mariages
dans l'hôtel de ville sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville brandissent des
drapeaux étrangers ou manifeste par des
danses des des spectacles les traditions
qui sont les leurs monsieur le président
comment vous dire je suis un peu je suis
un peu inquiet madame la députée
genevard quand je vous entends dire
entre autres choses ne pas résumer votre
propos à cela mais que son compatriote
réagir est mal quand ils le voient des
gens danser au moment de leur mariage
des danses qui sont des danses venues
d'ailleurs
alors je vous rappeler que certaines y
la vase autrichienne la sardane catalan
flamenco espagnol la salsa cubaine et le
smurf français moi madame la députée
quand je vois des gens danser ça me rend
heureux
alors alexis poulain là c'est un
ministre qui botte un peu on touche
parce que voilà il est passé à côté du
sujet clairement il ne répond pas à la
préoccupation de l'est de la butte
député loin peut-être dans gérald
darmanin qui se situe davantage sur la
droite du gouvernement qui peut être
nécessaire emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
oui complètement on voit très bien la
l'adn politique d'eric dupond moretti
lui qui se voulait être barrages ou
rassemblant nationale dans les hauts de
france on a vu l'état du barrage et puis
et puis évidemment de répondre salsa et
et autres danses alors que la député
faisait référence sans doute à des
coutumes d'afrique du nord évidemment
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
là encore pourquoi débattent de ce genre
de thématique à l'assemblée c'est vrai
pourquoi le ministre justice prend la
parole sur cette question là clairement
au sein de l'exécutif
il était un peu la caution encore de
gauche d'emmanuel mâcon ou du moins
progressiste mais sur ces questions là
notamment question de l'intégration du
respect des musulmans en france et on a
l'impression que tout ça est en train de
s'effriter avec la montée bien sûr des
discours identitaire d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron a parlé d'une société qui sera
sia lisent donc le président lui est
plutôt sur une autre ligne que celle
d'eric dupond-moretti donc c'est assez
effectivement lunaire assez étonnant de
voir ce ministre bien seul finalement
dans un gouvernement qui va de plus en
plus vers la droite que ce soit sur les
sujets économiques mais aussi les sujets
sociaux même si la pma a été votée il ya
quelques jours de cela la suite des
opérations pour les mois qui viennent
c'est les réformes réforme économique
celle des retraites celle de l'assurance
chômage etc
et puis des débats sur les sujets de
société qui seront ceux de la sécurité
bien sûr la place de la justice et bien
sûr les questions de l'immigration et de
la pression migratoire
enfin à moins d'un an des
présidentielles on assiste électio au
retour des des magistrats dans l'arène
politique
oui c'est un peu ce qui on peut voir on
se rappelle tous évidemment de la
campagne de 2017 et de l'arrivée
impromptue de la justice dans cette
campagne avec la sphère fillon à la
sphère pénélope fillon son emploi fictif
qui a valu finalement la campagne au
candidat des républicains
et là on sent bien que les magistrats
arrive avec un but faire tomber le
ministre de la justice cet ancien avocat
qui aurait eu des conflits d'intérêts
dans la sphère des des fadettes bien sûr
qu'ils s'attaquent à eux de l'intérieur
puisqu'il était en poste
à la tête du ministère et peut donc
avoir une liberté de mouvement que non
pas est ce que ça veut dire que derrière
ces magistrats politiques ont d'autres
visées est ce que c'est un coup de
semonce qui annonce d'autres actions
madame champrenault qui était à la tête
du parquet de paris prend sa retraite
elle a été clairement dans la la la la
la la lutte contre nicolas sarkozy et
les affaires qu'il y avait notamment des
fadettes et autres est ce que d'autres
magistrats sont en train de montrer
qu'il compte bien peser dans la campagne
présidentielle
en dix ans emmanuel macron attention
nous pourrions aussi accélérer le pas
sur les affaires qui concernent alexis
colère secrétaire général de l'elysée
pour richard ferrand il est hors de
cause puisqu'il ya prescription mais
d'autres comme gérald darmanin par
exemple pourrait aussi voir le dossier a
accéléré il ya beaucoup d'épée de
damoclès de la justice qui pendent au
dessus d'eux des ministres ou des
proches des manuels macron et ça c'est
peut-être un message qui est donnée
avant le début de la campagne
merci alexis poulain pour votre analyse